hallo me nameom meine Damen und Herren
ich mache heute mal wieder kahoot Quizes
von Fanpages allerdings heute mit dem
Themenschwerpunkt
Abitur es kommen also
intelligenzfragen bezogen auf drei
Abiturfächer von da starten wir direkt
mit Geografie für Idioten von Jessie aka
con_lugi wie heißt ein Nebenfluss des
[Musik]
reins ich hasse diese Bilder immer Lippe
Nase Fuß oder Ohr ihr denkt ihr könnt
mich damit kriegen aber ich weiß dass es
die Lippe ist ich komme aus eckebelefeld
lipstad ist eine Stadt bei uns in der
Nähe machen mal weiter mit Frage Nummer
2 wie heißt eine bekannte Stadt in
[Musik]
Marokko oh ich hasse euch so doll wir
haben als Antwortmöglichkeiten Bonus
Nachlass
ja wie kommt ihr auf so ein Schwachsinn
Frage Nummer 3 von S wie heißt ein Ort
auf den
Lofoten ich weiß nicht mehr was die
Lofoten ab CD ich kann ja noch raten ich
wür sagen
c
a ein Ort was sind überhaupt die Lofoten
Frankreich Frage Nummer 4 für welchen
Berg ist Südafrika
bekannt es ist tatsächlich der Tafelberg
aber könnt ihr bitte aufhören mit diesen
verfickten Bildern drittletzte Frage ist
eine wahr oder falschfrage gibt es den
Tafelberg
[Musik]
ja vorletzte Frage was versteht man
unter
[Musik]
möwenschiss eine Spezialität mit
schnapsmettwurst und Senf aus Schleswig
[Musik]
Holstein rin ein möwenförmiger See in
Thüringen eine Festung aus dem 17
Jahrhundert in vpom oder eine
morlandschaft in Niedersachsen die für
ihre Farbe bekannt ist ich würde erstens
ausschließen könnte zwar sein allerdings
ist das hier Geografie Quiz deswegen
eher ein
möwenförmiger See in Thüringen ergbt
allerdings auch keinen Sinn weil warum
sollte es dann möwenschiss heißen und
nicht möwensee deswegen würde ich das
auch ausschließen wir haben nur noch
zwei Antwortmöglichkeiten eine Festung
aus dem 17 Jahrhundert Mecklenburg
Vorpommern hat nichts mit Möwen zu tun
deswegen kann es nur das hier sein es
ist ein Schnaps letzte Frage welches
dieser landesspezifischen Regeln ist
frei
erfunden die loserpartei das kann sich
nicht kaugumi vom
[Musik]
Arzt man kann sich in in Singapur
kaugumi vom Arzt verschreiben lassen
gibt Abitur in Geographie ist schon mal
bestanden und von daher machen wir
direkt weiter mit dem zweiten Fach für
heute und zwar Geschichte für blöde von
Marlin aka best of lerts Frage Nummer
ein was war am 14 April
1883 oh mein
Gott ich dachte jetzt dann irgendein
geschichtliches Ereignis aber es geht
einfach um den Wochentag ja diger ich
kann einfach nur raten
Samstag Frage Nummer 2 wann begann der
Ostfeldzug der deutschen Wehrmacht im
Zweiten Weltkrieg es war der Westfeld
ach du Kacke diger das S Sirio Riso ich
ist das da hinten keine Ahnung Kevin
Papa
Platte Sandra und rewi okay es war der
Westfeldzug wann begann der im Zweiten
Weltkrieg na ja OBV wenn es den gab ich
Ken mich jetzt nicht so krass aus ob es
jetzt der Ost oder Westfeldzug war aber
wenn er dann im Zweiten Weltkrieg war
dann war OBV im Zweiten Weltkrieg der
Ostfeldzug hat nicht im Zweiten
Weltkrieg stattgefunden oder im 19
Jahrhundert 19 Jahrhundert auf gar
keinen Fall weil er obvious Sie was mit
den denke ich mal beiden Weltkrieg die
waren beide waren beide im 20
Jahrhundert ich würde sagen es war der
festfeld
Zug okay okay Frage Nummer 3 von A wie
hieß der Tag Montag im alten Rom der
hieß tatsächlich
[Musik]
Montag was wann meldete Carl Benz im 18
Jahrhundert seinen ersten Motorwagen zum
Patent an gar nicht weil es war kein
Motorwagen mit autofragen kriegt ihr
mich nicht in welchem Jahr wurde die
NATO
gegründet die NATO existiert nicht in
einem Jahr mit 365 Tagen boah das ist
schwierig nein oh mein Gott ich bin so
blöd dritt letetzte Frage wie wollte
Karl Marx die soziale Frage unter
anderem lösen
[Musik]
mit mit dem Klimawandel mit der
Abschaffung von Steu mit einer Antwort
oder gar nicht die soziale Frage das
sind so Fangfragen ich sage einfach also
mit den oberen beiden auf gar keinen
Fall ich würde sagen mit einer
Antwort ich h euch so doll vorletzte
Frage für das zweite von den drei Quizes
wenn der sechste deutsche Bundeskanzler
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland ein
Gemüse wäre wäre es Zucchini
[Musik]
Gurke oh mein Gott Frage wer hat die
Türkei
gegründet
s mustafha Kim mal
Atatürk ich sagen atürk ist Name der mir
auf jeden Fall was sagt und vielleicht
hat er dann Türkei abgeleitet von seinem
Nachnamen oh mein
Gott ich hätte gedacht ich wä vierter
oder so komm damit jetzt allerdings auch
schon zum letzten der drei tfächer für
heute und zwar Sport für unsportliche
von Mona aka theers Frage Nummer 1 wie
nennt sich diese
Übung ich muss
groß Situps Kniebeugen oder ich senke
mich auf Lukas Niveau nee das ist noch
viel tiefer das sind tatsächlich die
Kniebeugen geil okay hier freue ich mich
frage Nummer 2 was passierte bei Diana
Ross super B halftime Show in 196 90 sie
stürzte von der Bühne und hatte einen
Oberschenkel halsbruch sie flog mit
einem Helikopter aus dem Stadion und
sang i will survive die Show musste
aufgrund eines stromhausfolls
unterbrochen werden oder sie hielt den
Rekord für die meist besuchte
Halbzeitshow das kann nicht sein
deswegen glaube ich sie stürzt und
kriegt ein Oberschenkel Hals sie ist mit
einem Helikopter
weggeflogen die singt und haut einfach
währenddessen ab Frage Nummer 3 welchen
Eishockey Spieler gibt es
wirklich Peter silie ach du Kacke crispy
bacon oh mein Gott kack mir in die
[Musik]
H
Adrian safe
[Musik]
der ich kack mir in dieos ich könn Frage
Nummer 4 in welchen Jahren gewann
Deutschland die WM das kann ich dir
sagen 54 74 90
2014 2014 ein dicker ach Mo da bin ja
ich frage 5 von 7 was störte 2020 die
segelbundesliga in Hamburg oh
nein ein Schwarm riesiger Fische ein
Unwetter ein containerfisch auf F Kurs
oder Laa und seine Freunde im
Schlauchboot oh mein
Gott
wir aber gut machen wir weiter mit der
vorletzten Frage Formel 1 in kam
Rennsport ist die teuerste Sport die es
gibt das ist tatsächlich oh das ist mein
Auto ich würde tatsächlich sagen also es
ist halt total schwierig wie willst du
das jetzt sagen also von den bezahlten
Sportlern her ist es das auf jeden Fall
nicht aber von den Kosten her würde ich
schon sagen
ja
okay die müssen halt immer um die Welt
fliegen und so ein Formel 1 Team ist
auch nicht so wie so ein Fußballteam das
alle in Flieger passen sondern die hab
noch riesig viele Trucks und so immer
von daher würde ich sagen kommen wir
jetzt auch schon zur letzten Frage für
heute wie viele Disziplinen umfassen die
olympischen Spieler heute wir haben 103
102 what das sind alles so viele das
kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen so
viele Disziplinen nee nee ne nee 103
302 ich bin so krass ne wenn ich jetzt
in drei Fächern ich hatte in allen drei
Fächern den ersten Platz das gab es noch
nie bei einem Kaho Video Freunde wenn es
euch gefallen hat Tommy ist mein Cousin
ich bin sein Onkel